欢迎收看最佛心幽默的财经节目
理财达人秀
我是李兆华
今天南部依旧是好雨的天气
希望大家出路是平安的
所以今天的交易量
还是比较偏低的
不过今天的盘式
跟昨天倒是完全相反
昨天尾盘杀下来杀了400多点
今天拉尾盘
拉了400多点上去
两边互换
所以今天是开低走高盘
整个体感温度完全不一样
好那大家要问现在的感受是
上去有压力
下来的话会默默的看到
有一只手在接
美国的财政部出手了
说他们有机会动用1兆美元
1兆美元来购买他们的债券
把这个公债值利率稍微压下来
其实这个举动很重要
因为它要让整体的科技股恢复信心
美股往上走
台股自然接下来就有机会带动
因为我们现在虽然盘中有下跌将近500点
可是整体来说
我们算是横盘整理相当强势
亮缩就在等一个表态
当然希望接下来的表态是往上
而我们很多的证据告诉您
往上的几率比较高
来欢迎今天的三位来宾
第一位是AI達人蔡明翰
好看到明翰就知道
为什么往上的几率比较高
刚刚提到了
美国政府说有机会拿出一兆美元
其实不管他有没有买
说出这句话就赢一半
那接下来是不是我们就等于
站在一个起跑点起攻点之上呢
要克服哪一些难关呢
克服之后呢
其实明翰今天很佛心
已经帮我们列出来
他心目中的梯队
谁是第一梯队
PCB 設備股這類型的
獲利非常高的就是列在第一梯隊
等一下民漢的表哥仔細看起來囉
好 第二位呢
是齊全王子張林中 鐘哥
好 鐘哥說他在齊全手碼上
有一個大發現
等一下後來跟大家聊
不過盤式比較黏比較悶也是真的
今天用他慣用的手法
KD 黃金交叉
其實有一個利多的例子叫做光寶科
帶動誰呢
大家很關心的聯電
有沒有可能低檔往上攻喔
再來航海王現在真的這幾天好熱喔人人都想當今天輪到散裝航運其實散裝航運有聰明融資跑進來囉等一下鐘哥也會告訴您到底還有沒有肉可以吃哦
好第三位是我們的
古奇雙分析師紀維銘小明同學
好小明同學一直在觀察通膨的數據哦
他說接下來公布的數據
都可能顯示呢
通膨會降溫
上一次的CPI明天有PCE
好不過這些數據降溫
最重要的就是剛剛提到的
公債殖利率要往下压
往下压科技股就能出头
台湾他认为上游的IC设计
非常有机会继续往上冲
美国呢
美国最好先看
七巨头的回暖
到底回答财报后
据说是跌多涨少
可是这正是一个好的机会
有相关的ETF
我们带您来了解
好 首先有请米汉哥
好 最近的盘比较门
量也比较小
所以今天需要你振奋人心
台政部说有可能拿出1兆美元来救债
是不管有没有
你觉得台股现在就在一个起跑点
蓄势代工的路上
帮我们列出来了AI的第一梯队
好我们先讲
先讲1兆美元救债
到底有没有效果
他就提到这个财长有提及
接近1兆美元的账户要来回购
我答案两点
第一点没有用
只是這個金額
對比40兆美元的這個
整個所謂債務
其實對比而已
而且還有一個問題
他這一兆美元不可能都用
不太可能都用
對 所以老實講
效果是很差
但是這是第一個結論
第二個結論
就是整個美債殖利率的問題
根本就不是問題
這兩個有點納悶
我們等一下細講就知道
先講一下
這個是外資體積的
他認為說
為什麼公債殖利率下不去
而且應該說暫時下不去
可是他也提到長線不會是
這個導致經濟反轉的因素
第一個呢就是因為經濟太好
經濟太好自然就沒有人要去買債券
因為通常都是經濟有問題
要避險的才去買債券
那最近的經濟數據太好
另外有這通膨
現在通膨老實說已經有開始往下
但是最近呢應該說你看的時間多長
如果長線它趨勢往下
但短線因為
暫火還沒有結束
最近又在那邊震盪
所以這個卡住的情況下認為
整公債殖利率是下不去
另外一個可能大家都沒有去發現的事情
他又提到海外的一些因素也導致美債殖利率維持高檔其中提到英國跟日本這兩個國家他們的海外的一個所謂的債事的外溢效應
這什麼事情
其實美債殖利率一直走高
代表著美債的價格是往下的
但往下照理講資金就會進來買
可是還有兩個也是一樣
就是英國跟日本也是殖利率走高
兩個債券也很便宜
大家都很便宜
很多都很便宜
然後呢資金只有一套
當你要買美國的時候發現
英國日本也很便宜
所以他們這兩個就會拉著
美國的這個殖利率
還在持續走高
他這是要講概念
就在講這個第三點的部分
另外一點
其實我覺得這個才是最重要的
就是AI資本支出
持續在創高
第二個結論就是告訴大家
其實美債殖利率根本就不用緊張
美債殖利率根本
不是股市下跌的元兇
這就是我的論點
那為什麼看
看這張圖就可以知道
這個是美債子綠綠色藍色的線
那紅色的是廢半
最近發生的現象就是在這個最高點
就是來到這個5.34%
等於是創
07年以來的新高
大家很害怕
那我給大家看一個圖是說什麼
這段時間
其實當時4月的時候
如果還沒有看到這一段
當時4月的時候來到5.2%
其實當時也是創歷史新高
可是問題在哪裡
因為廢半不斷往上漲
股市多投
大家就不覺得這是問題
現在開始震盪了
大家就覺得這個是問題
我常講只要這個紅色線再一往上勾
即使後續藍色線再創高
大家也不理他
所以我常常講的
到底是債券殖利率創高
導致股市跌
還是因為股市跌了
大家才認為
大家才看到債券殖利率創高
我個人覺得債券殖利率創高
其實並不用太擔心
如果真的經濟
真的反轉向下
你看到了債券殖利率會快速往下股
股市也會同步往下
這才是經濟有問題
前段不重要
真的揮答才是重點
好 揮答的財報即將要公布
那你有做了一個很有趣的統計
對 應該我們先講
為什麼說這個才是重點
記得就是今年上半年能夠
股市能夠漲五成就是AI的需求
重點要看哪兩個
第一個是毛利率
因為毛利率公司給的是75
但是市場也不敢再往上拉
因為照理講現在成本不斷拉升它應該是會往下所以大家覺得沒有錯你只要穩住75就已經非常厲害另外一個是下一季的這個營收直營要比這一季要再更高
等於要超過1000以上
另外一個呢
我們上次來也提到
現在的這個AI伺服器的需求
有6成來自大型雲端
那其他中小型的接近25%
24%
但比較重要不是這個表
你要去看一下這幾年的表現
大型的從兩年前700億到現在1300億接近倍增
可是它的佔比是從66一路到現在的60
那中小型的部分呢
這個資金是接近三倍的成長之外
重點它的比例從16現在攀升到24
這個為什麼這個概念
就是整塊我常講這塊餅在擴大
可是我們要看到的是大型雲端業者的比例
希望越來越小
為什麼 因為代表著
大家不用擔心
只靠那三四家
或者四五家
然後呢他們已經
賺的錢都投完了
自由現金流都轉付了
明年不知道成長從哪來的時候
就是靠著中小型能夠
所謂的持續推升
再告訴大家
近實際的
回答法說結論就是
永遠都是猶有預期
但是股價的走勢
看到藍色的圖
這個一是法說會的隔一天
五天 十天 十五天
你會發現
大概低點是在法縮會完的5到6天
好 所以等於不管怎樣優於預期
都要先歷經下跌
對 都必須歷經下跌 為什麼那麼殘忍呢
對 這個跟台積電這次法縮會一樣
那你會發現它下跌的過程當中
它會帶著綠色
就是台積電也會跟著下跌
加權指數當然也會受到影響
對 所以但是就是一個禮拜時間
整個禮拜過後
它會慢慢又發散掉
最後時間再拉長
又會變成台積電表現最好
反而又與輝達加選指數相對
落後一些些
但趨勢是往上的
大致上這個架構稍微理解
而且要提醒大家就是說
這個前面還有法術會前
那就過去紀錄
就算法術會前下跌了
通常法術會後還是得跌
所以
因為輝達已經連漆黑
正想問說輝達已經連漆黑了
結果沒想到還是一樣
過往紀錄還是會跌
所以就是法
我常常講這段時間
大家就冷靜一下
所以也不要說
最近好像表現不是很好
你壓力已經很大
我會擔心法社會
你壓力會更大
當你受不了的時候
剛好這邊賣掉的時候
他就開始轉強
所以你自己節奏要抓穩
大致上就是這樣趨勢
所以短線震盪整理
尤其是剛剛提到
這個甚至都已經跌破季線
來到月線
你看一下人家廢半
甚至在
甚至都本來就已經在月線
附近震盪
甚至在月線之下
所以台股老實講
到目前為止
還是算是非常強勢的一個市場
另外再講到
這個回過頭來金融族群
今天就很強了
今天很厲害
我覺得他們有反映
就是美國就債也好
或是說我們有在戶這個指數也好
對 到底這兩個
我覺得應該說戶指數的
相對比較合理
因為美債殖利率走高
到底對他
這個到底是多還是空
不是不利嗎
對 照理講很明顯就是不利
因為你要知道
殖利率走高代表在
債券價格是往下
對 那誰手上最多債券
就是這種受險期的金光
對 他們買了一頭拉庫
所以照理講他們是利空
那你說
可是你這個是金融指數
另外公債殖利率
你會發現說
可是你要看到
之前大漲的這段時間
其實殖利率是往下
還是有影響
所以往下的時候
反而是對他們來講是比較有利的
所以我個人覺得
純粹就是資金的避風港
也不代表說一定是某人要來
買這個來戶什麼指數
我覺得倒不至於
但是記得
你不要看到牆了
就覺得要追來長暴
這故事又不一樣
長報金融股是合理的
我覺得AI族群
有一點點的金融下去做
所謂的衛星配置是合理的
但是你不能等到轉牆的時候
你才要追來長線長報
這個就不合理
但是至少他這樣一個表態
創下2001年掛牌來的新高
真的是蠻猛的
他也可以算是一個資金避風
最近大家心情比較防禦
但等到輝塔開完他的財報之後
可能就有機會轉到科技股了
是 那所以應該說
如果長報的投資人現在不要
但是短線的
反而現在資金幣瘋港
你可以趁著這段時間
在金工股做一個短線的操作
是 好那這邊的話
因為你是AI達人嘛
所以還是列出了你的AI第一梯隊
好簡單來講就是AI佔比高
然後有獲利數值
然後現在的角度
雖然相對比較弱勢
震盪的時候可以佈局
那其中PCB的部分
我們就抓這個CCL包含窄版包含PCB的個股那結論可以看到就是所謂的去年成長今年成長 明年還會成長營收 累積營收
所有能篩選的關卡都幫你篩一次
最起碼他都是非常穩健
那除了PCB之外 設備族群
然後包含老AI
其實大部分也都符合相關的條件
那當然啊 這個所謂的組裝廠
大家可能又覺得
毛利率
對毛利率或者相對比較牛
那最基本來講PCB設備來講
就比較不會有這些不利因子
但我個人覺得啦
也真的我覺得
毛利率低是他們的產業結構
這倒不是問題那麼大
只要不要再持續往下
我覺得都還算
維持比較正向的發展
個股的部分
就是剛剛提到宰板
現在就是高檔震盪
宰板有打到季線
對
就我個人覺得也都還是可以持續關注
另外旺席的部分
就是法縮會之後就崩盤的個股
但是只要記得一個問題
公司就有講
他不是需求沒有任何改變
現在他們的問題是做不出來
那為什麼大家失望是因為
有點類似所謂的提前拉貨
第二季大幅憂鬱期
結果導致第三季沒東西可交
所以幾乎變成沒有成長力道
所以導致市場的
這個所謂失望性賣壓
未來簡單而言
它現在是全產全銷
它未來業績面要上去只有兩條路
一個就是調漲價格
另外一個就是新產能出來
調漲價格要等第一世紀
然後他們產能必須等明年
真正爆發力一定是未來
所以應該這樣講
現在投入你也不要想要V型反轉
但是如果你用季節性的角度來看的話
第三季絕對是一個佈局的點位
因為下一季報價
應該說產品價格就會調漲
明年的這個產能一出來
它的營收又回到正常的一個成長軌道
所以
反而第三季應該是大家最不看的時間點
反而是佈局的一個機會
好 我們再來講
就是第二梯隊
就是AI佔比來講還不是那麼高
然後這個族群
我就會建議真的轉牆再買
因為為什麼就是
AI佔比不高
大家現在買的都是
觀念就是它未來AI佔比會很高
可是老實講會有變數
而且有時候
第一個是有變數
就是未來會不會拉不上去
另外一個是
股價會不會反應太快
這兩點真的很難拿
所以如果你下來攤平我會擔心最後才發現拉不上去或者是你那個時候買的時候是一個太高的價位你就會套的時間比較長所以建議就是你不要去
預估多少價錢是底部
你就讓它打完底
轉牆再買
我覺得這是很重要的觀念
我們剛剛提到CPU的部分
相對比我個人覺得
對比下面又再好一點
就是它的AI進程是最穩定的
可是它這個族群的缺點就是
如果真的獲利很好的
通常本益比都會非常非常高
而且都已經接近前高了
他們算反彈非常強勁的
是 所以我剛剛講的就是
基歐股很貴很貴
然後你減便宜的又發現
績效又沒那麼好
所以就有點尷尬
至於被動記憶體
矽晶圓就有點像就是AI佔比不高
但是記憶體的
它的獲利面非常好
是因為這種外溢的效應
所以稍微又有點區別
但唯一的缺點就是現在市場
只剩下一檔南亞科
其他的通常都沒有太大表現
所以如果你今天要操作
就只有一檔就是南亞科
因為他就是轉強在買
所以你一定是以南亞科為主軸
那其他如果個股來講
就可以看到聯亞
因為剛剛提到數字很好
持續往上攻高
我覺得是可以持續留意
那矽晶圓的部分
台勝科就算是
股價相對比較強勢的
但我剛剛提到
矽晶圓他的基本面
對比剛剛所有族群裡面
真的是相對比較弱
包含營收 獲利
都還是相對比較弱
大家都是展望未來
可是未來我剛剛提到
未來是有風險的
所以記得一件事情
能突破你再去買賺價差
但是如果拉回的時間點
絕對不要向下攤平
好 聯亞這個可以說是
細光子裡面的領頭羊代表
他都已經漲到快要接近前高了
可是他的營收確實成長的
那個速度比率非常高
財政科剛轉虧為盈
可是他確實現在的話
他也是橫盤整理
你感覺上要突破
都是要這個要買牆對不對
是 聯亞如果回檔呢
聯亞回檔
有一個問題
他100多倍的被益
所以你不知道回到哪裡合理
所以我就跟他講
在回檔的過程你也先不要接
你必須要等到他指紋的時候再買
會相對比較安全
所以我覺得兩個故事不同
但是最好都還是等轉牆再買
會相對比較安全
要不然就是去接第一批
對啦
是 這邊非常謝謝明翰哥
好 明翰先說
這個1兆美元可能不會用
也可能不夠用啦
但是口頭上當然要宣告一下讓這個債市平穩一些另外一方面的思考是債券殖利率的走高其實並不是牌面上的大重點大重點我們回到AI的資本支出
再持續的推進
還有回答財報後
不管表現多好都要先蹲一下
可是可以看完後續
蹲完繼續往上走
這才是台股美股
準備起功的一個重要訊號
所以剛剛也講到了
AI純度高的海鯊心目中的第一首選
列出來了第一梯隊
第一梯隊就是
如果有回檔是可以安心撿的
第二梯隊如果持續在強勢的路上
也可以放心去追
但是要看您的投資風險屬性
提供給您
好廣告回來的話
鐘哥要上場啦
那鐘哥也要講
他過去講的KD黃金交叉有高有低
例如現在光寶科好強喔
就是黃金交叉在高檔
那聯電就有機會跟上來喔
等一下來告訴你
如何航海王上面也能占到便宜喔
現在很多爸媽會幫小朋友存股
而且是一出生就去買護國神山台積電
那衛浪老師
如果我每個月定期訂額扣一萬塊的話
到小朋友18歲的時候可以存到多少錢
又到我跟你說
以年化報酬率8%估算
孩子18年總共投入216萬元
負利累積之後
等到成年直接就衝破了480萬
台積電是靠技術負利領先全球
而孩子的成長發育期其實也是一種負利
而且黃金成長期如果一旦錯過了
就再也買不回來了
像莊廣和堂 轉大人翠滴金
由台灣第一位女中醫師
莊熟期博士開立
有曾外孫三胞胎成長實證
男女不同的成龍 成鳳配方
精準補給黃金期的營養
存台積電是幫孩子累積財富
把握黃金成長期是在幫孩子累積未來競爭力
幫孩子存股票
更別忘了幫孩子存未來
孩子的成長不能等喔
好 接下來的盤勢真的相對黏
所以鐘哥要提出在齊全籌碼上的一些觀察
以及其實他之前教我們的
KD黃金交叉向上
依舊可以選到很多的好股票
以及聰明融資
很多人對聰明融資還是沒搞懂
今天鐘哥再交一次
聰明融資有跑來買航運
到底什麼是聰明融資
還蠻多觀眾朋友
每次看完都會問
到底為什麼他就聰明
有的就是該被掃出去呢
那再來剛剛提到
輝達的財報有三個情境
但是剛才看民漢的情境
就是要先跌
所以你這邊也是說先跌
所以先跌之後的策略要給我們
好 那其實那個就歷史的
統計看起來的確是先跌沒錯
那我們來看過去的四次好了
這個框框上面我們是
有五次的財報
我們往前看前一次是
2026年5月21號
就離我們最近的那一次
我們看驚喜程度就好了
大概是6%左右
剛才明漢其實有說
每一次他都一定會優於預期
這是這個揮答的習慣
但是大家已經不太重要
已經不喜歡這個
就像7月17號
台积电法说会
说了98分没用
大盘是跌了两三千点
类似这样的概念
所以前一次经济程度是6.52
那我们来看这一次就好了
礼拜四
那预估是2.09
那经济程度要多少
这个大盘
这个挥达才会上涨
多少
如果你超过10%
我觉得可能有机会
可以稍微止跌一下
如果你还是6% 7%
因为你往前去看
过去这边是4%
然后3.1%
5.51%
其实都没有用
你看它只要讲完
在这个圈圈讲完
大概就是前几天
都是会稍微修正一下
那再来我们来看
我们说针对这种
不论是挥达
那挥达可能比较少人有
那大概是相关的供应链
我想就很多人有
比如像这个鸿海广达
伪创围影等等
这种AI相关的
那第一个是我们已经持有它
那如果你是长期持有
你对AI持有很长线的信仰的话
你就不用管它
不用管它了
那我们讲的是比较中短线
像我们这种就是
做五天的
对 短冲载
财报前可能就会适度减码
礼拜四以前
那再来就是
如果你准备追价
你就不要在礼拜四以前去中压
稍微听看听一下
那第三种就是
你等待财报后交易
因为指数修正后
通常是中长线的买点
那这个你可以搭配什么
你可以搭配像VIX
如果礼拜四你看到
灰达跌得比较深
那我想科技股
应该会跌得比较重
VIX應該會稍微往上彈一下
其實你看VIX最近也不動
對啊 怎麼東西都不動
超級無聊
所以你看最近的盤就是很無聊
無論是多空
其實下方或是上方空間都不大
都還滿小的
那除了這一頁之外
我們再來看這個
那這就是剛才明翰
大家提過這樣的概念
財報公布之後的這個前後五天
通常是一個震盪期
那這個大概1%到3%左右的跌幅
好 震盪或下跌那重點是T加20天就是也許在9月底以前你這樣看這个报酬率会来到这个3%到4%上升了对 那如果你是看30天的话
大概会到7%到8%左右
那再来我们来看这个
简单归纳一下
过去三年它已经确立
财报一定会超过预期的常态
所以如果这一次不到2.09
就完蛋了
简单来说就是这样
因为以前都好就还是要跌
不过可能可以逆向思考
如果假设1.5好了
也许会大涨
那这个机遇真的太低了
刚刚讲的惊喜的%数
就是超出多少的意思吗
超出多少
所以一定要2.9以上
2.09以上
对 但是可能还是会先跌
所以单纯的击败预期
已经不会推动股价
可能大家注重就是
它未来的指引
还有这个新旧产品交替
是否會有卡關
也許是個不太順利的狀況
毛利率都要注意
所以明漢中哥我們現在對
這個仁勳哥提出了暫帖
看他如何在這一次講完
然後可以直接上漲
對 那我們看這個兩種情境
這個情境就是我們剛剛一直在談的
財報加股價下跌
那我覺得這個大概有80%
那20%是這個
就是財報加 財測強
股價真的就大漲
那如果大漲怎麼辦呢
AI它再一次的重新發動的多方點
我覺得就在這一天
就禮拜四可能會發生
但是我覺得
機率是這個比較高一點
但還是不排除有這樣的可能
但也沒關係啊
因為先蹲後跳嘛
大家還有點時間做布局
只是信心要有
是 就整個長線還是多方
沒有太大問題
那當然短線震盪
我們就看一下資金的變化
好
那上方是這個納斯達克
對 那中間這個是道瓊
好 道瓊
只要有两个K棒
我们就可以去算谁强谁弱
是
那我们往下去看
最近不是有点整理吗
对
8月1号开始反弹
大盘反弹这个指标是红色
对
代表钱跑到纳斯达克
就是科技股
好 这边开始变化了
到8月18的时候
指标不是翻成绿色吗
对
代表你的传产开始比较抗跌
那你的纳斯达克稍微比较弱一些
所以你看大盘就是不好
它的公式我们简单解释一下
把上面剪下面
就是納斯达克剪掉道琼
再去除以兩個相加那這是我們之前談過的概念所以如果指標是綠色的話我們現在就是買傳產空科技可能相對會比較容易賺到錢確實現在台股傳產的風也很強
等一下會講到的航運也是啊
沒有錯 對
所以我們從資金面看起來
道雄還是真的比較強勢一些
那當然是美國
我們看一下台灣是不是也是
如果美國是科技比較弱
台灣科技比較強
當然有時候會這樣子
不過通常是同步的
我們看這是台灣
那上面是台紫期一樣
台子期 一樣是小時限
那一樣8月開始談對不對
談的時候指標一定是紅色的
因為電子股比較強
金融股它大概就是防守
所以你看 談到這個地方
談到這個地方指標是綠色
一樣是大概在8月14、15左右
這一段下來就是弱勢整理
弱勢整理
一直到這個
其實上週五有一度出現紅色
因為那一天大盤是漲
指標開始偏綠對不對
所以這邊還是稍微弱勢一點
今天是禮拜二
所以下半周還有三天
如果這邊一直都是綠色的話
我覺得這個盤往上的空間相對受限
那你剛才一開始說齊全籌碼
我有一個重大的發現
什麼發現 就是沒有什麼用
沒有什麼用
最近沒有什麼用
你大半輩子在這上面
你說沒有什麼用
不是很沮喪嗎
我也不會
因為我發現散戶籌碼
我會用它來看過去40天的均值
你看它過去40天在這邊
大概是33000口左右
那目前是28000附近
只要比过去均值要低
代表对大盘是加分
但加分你不能直接去买进
你要搭配大盘要过前三天的高
所以你看如果这个盘
慢慢的往下整理的话
它并没有过前三天的高
我们就不适合买
你反而在这个地方
可能有机会可以做多
为什么
因为它这边是比较少的筹码
然后这个指数是过前三天的高
那这一波外资期货
一直都是空单
对
那这个也不重要
你要看它的现货
是
这一波从低点上来
大概买了3500亿
就是外资现货买
大盘就会涨
期货就不用管它
那如果外资现货卖
因为它期货空单还是很多
大盘就不太会动
所以这一波的逻辑
大概是这样子
那你说上我觉得
因为7月大跌
对
那8月大涨
那接下来的波动率
一定会降低
那波动率降低的话
大盘就会很无聊
就会回到个股表现
是
這個機率高一點
因為像今天拉尾盤的時候
很多個股是急速上拉所以個股的表現有的還蠻精彩的對 那再來我們來看這個兩個條件一個就是營收年增超過35%再來是接近持股超過150檔的那這六檔一定是未來的主角
不管是多空的話
那你看我們看月線
台積電勉強站上對不對
那台光電勉強在上面
那台達電弱勢
他一直最近還算稍微止跌一些
不過前面修正已經很多了
對 我們一直受暖他
一直希望他趕快
因為廣寶科上去
但是我覺得他還是有機會
然後畢竟是同樣的這個族群
那智邦這就是跌到這個月線的下方
那齊鴻漲多壓回
那這個是旺席
旺席現在也沒有在月線上
所以你從這個盤面主角看起來
就是也不夠整齊
對 那可能相對就是我覺得還是盤整
好 盤整盤
盤整盤就看個股表現
剛剛有講到個股也有精彩的
光寶貴今天再創新高
再創歷史新高
而且你說他不但創新高
它的指标让它后续还是有推动力
对 我们今天选股有两个大主轴
一个就是KD黄金交叉
然后均线上扬 股期量比较多一些
我们一直在强调
KD黄金交叉这个不太容易发生
比如说KD如果大于低的话
这种股票很多 可能大概有几百档
但是你要黄金交叉
在今天可能就只会有10档以内
那你要搭配其他的均线跟股期交易量
其实并不多
所以从昨天到现在
大概只有三档符合
只有三档
就是光宝科 联电
还有下一页的那一位
第一个我们先看光宝科
我想这一波的上攻反弹
大盘你看跟大盘比就知道了
大盘其实没有过高
那它已经过高
过它的这个前高的位置
那KD一样
它在最近黄金交叉
那我们说这边的黄金交叉
我们不用管位阶
不管在20 50 80
它只要交叉
它就是好股票
所以它就是可以持续的留意一下
那如果你不喜欢追高没关系
压回等待靠近均线再去进场
可能会比较适合一些
那连电你看啊
前高在185.5
这一波下来
弹甚至都弹不到一半
因为大盘已经弹到一半上
所以它就是相对比较弱势
成熟至神大家都是这样子
那现在看起来KD在50以下
黄金交叉
我觉得你可以留意一下
因为它的这个现金持续率
这个题材会吸引到一些
这个在大盘比较成本的时候
法輪會進駐
所以這可以去觀察一下
那第三檔就是金豪科
我最強的啊
對 那基底
我覺得最近表現都還不錯
都是在前高右上角附近
所以一樣
黑棒的高點
最後一根你要留意一下
像今天是黑棒
高點把它畫起來
後面如果有過它的話
你可以重新再進場
那當然KD在50附近交叉
這個位階相對也是在一個
比較有利的位置
可以看一下這樣
有時候看到已經在前高附近了
會覺得有點壓力
但很奇妙
高就是會更高
因為它指標或是法人的集中度
就是比較好
而且我們看那個均線的斜率
像你看這邊明顯是往下掉的
那股價在這一段就不太容易上漲
那現在看起來它從大幅的走秧
雖然它是有點走平
但它沒有掉下來
所以它可能還是有表現的機會
這也是一個三選的方式
好 最近的話
當然眼光又回到了航運身上
我們有開玩笑說
大家好像肌肉記憶裡面都有航運
一講到航運興致都非常高
今天講的兩檔
一個散裝一個貨櫃
因為在2021年的時候
航海網讓大家可能賺到不少錢
大家好像對這個滿有興趣的
用古旗應該那時候也很驚鎬駭浪
對 很多人用古旗
在那一波賺了很多很多錢
一樣我們這個條件
是用跟剛才不太一樣
類似 第一個
均線它是上升的
然後融資增加前100檔
就是市場上面
增加前100檔的股票
大家都說不是在去槓桿嗎
為什麼要選融資
因為我們透過量化回測發現
你加上這個條件
绩效会变得很好
也就是说有人问说
是不是因为股价是往多方走
他就算聪明融资
某种程度是
对他没错
他就是会赚到钱
那第三个就是
我们的基金持有超过10党
那10党当然不太多
那我们把它加上去
那再来是本益比小于40倍
那这个还蛮重要的
这个在最近这个
股价大盘震荡的时候
你加上这个
其实你的绩效变得比较平滑
以前我们就买
如果买太贵的话
其实很容易受伤
好 那我们就看有三档
第一个是2606的育民
那今天一度冲上涨停
那我们其实我们在昨天收盘就选出来了
那进场点是开盘价
所以大概9点
8.45分附近
所以今天可以抓到一个还不错的红棒
那阳明今天有点开高走低
那不过因为他协率有点高
在最近才被我们捞出来
然后这第二档
两档都有点高档
这个顿化
过热的问题所以回档的话会比较好介入吗對 你就等他回來例如說再重新突破黑棒高點再重新進場也是不錯那玉金光這一波修正下來現在大概談到一半左右
那我們選股方式
這個KD在這個地方
有不錯的交叉機會
均線正在上揚
而且融資最近增加比較多一些
所以我覺得它後續的續航力
應該還可以稍微琢磨一下
因為剛好這三檔
他們真的算是相對強勢股
所以強勢股的話
會建議這個時候
時間點強短嗎
我覺得可以
但你的停損停力
節奏要設的短一點
好 但是現在看起來
資金只有一套嗎
剛剛明漢也講
也許就是集中在這些族群上面
好 非常謝謝鐘哥
好 以期權來說
最近的盤真的比較黏一點點
比較無聊一點點
連VIX指標也沒有太大的波動
所以要在這個行情裡面
找機會的話
第一個 外資先看現貨
現貨持續買台股就容易往上走
第二個就看個股表現囉
剛剛講到的KD黃金交叉向上不多
可能篩出來每天就10檔而已
雖然現在篩出來有蠻多是比較偏高位階一點點的
但先不要管高低位階
它的續航力是可以期待的
還有加入了聰明融資會發現
大家真的很想當海海王
但如果您是這個時候才想要介入的話
短線上的操作為宜
或是等到回檔再重新起工
這樣會是一個比較安全的買法
好廣告回來
小明同學要上場了
小明同學也說
接下來的通膨指標
幫我們先預測
都有可能降溫
降溫供債殖利率
又有機會往下壓的話
科技股的春天就來啦
台灣的話
他看IC設計
美國的話
看七巨頭要來表現
有一檔ETF
是可以打包
美股的科技七巨頭
其實現在投資朋友
對於布局到台灣
美國
心裡面都有概念了
尤其是AI發達的這個世代
兩邊佈置都很重要
但是說實話
中小型股還是以台股為主
美國科技巨頭隨時有機會發威
因為剛剛前面兩位來賓有特別聊到
揮答雖然會先蹲
但後面是一路往上的
所以如果今天通膨真的有機會降溫
台灣你會建議買上游來設計
美國的話七巨頭把它統包
對 因為我們在
接下來要面對到的是
PCE通膨數據大魔王同時還有輝達財報剛剛前面兩位專家都聊過了那我來先跟大家講一下關於總金的部分在明天要公布的PCE物價指數上來說我認為7月份其實不需要太擔心
因為我們前面已經有先偷看過考卷了
CPI公布出來符合市場預期
那時候大漲
那時候是大漲的
所以PCE通常這個時候就不會有什麼太大的變動
6月份的年增率3.7
這次公布出來市場預期大概是3.6
稍微降溫一點點
核心PC的部分呢 會持平差不多在3.3
所以沒有什麼太大的變化
可是這次有個問題是市場的預測分佈很窄
什麼叫做很窄
所謂的很寬就是有人預估很高 有人預估很低
所以很窄就是大家的共識都差不多
跟現在的股票市場一樣就對了
對 就是沒什麼波動啦
那大摩自己估的核心PC月增是0.22
那其實大家大概都是這個數字
所以呢 真正呢 會讓股市被嚇到大跌的
應該是公布出來
如果核心PCE這個數字大於0.3的話
才有可能發生
我認為機率不大啦
我認為機率不大
那我們整體來講的話
因為目前這個數據是不失控的
我們講過了
CPS符合市場預期
那再來
如果PCE可以符合市場預期
升息的風險就會下降
升息的風險下降
美債殖利率的壓力就會降低
降低完以後
科技成長股的估值環境就會改善
所以我們想要做的交易
就是要這條邏輯鏈
好 那我們現在以目前的
市場預期來講的話
市場認為啊
9月份應該就是不升息了啦
當時大家都認為應該要升息
那即便到現在喔
我還是認為到年底之前
聯準會是有可能不升的
有可能
好小明同學是不升派的
對我們目前是
我們就看你贏到什麼時候
好我們來繼續看下去
那當然啦
現在因為10月份市場是認為大概
升息一碼的機率46
那不升42
一半一半
所以我們就會看到
PC的數據真的公布出來以後
或許這個數字還會有變動
那同時啊
我們在接下來會遇到的這禮拜五
有所謂的 Jackson Hole 全球央行年會
這一次我會特別在意的就是華許他在演說上面
會不會提到關於聯準會的架構出現改變
例如說資產負債表有沒有需要變得更小
或者是他認為理想中的聯準會的功能是什麼
這些對於短線上面的市場不會有什麼太大的影響
但是對於長線上面
我們怎麼去觀察聯準會的貨幣政策
會有很大的變化
那當然這個真的 Jackson Hole 過後
達仁秀應該還是會來幫大家做分析啦
那再來的話就會去看看
這一陣子股價一直被壓抑的
高估值的IC設計股所以我們的邏輯會這樣順下來在更早之前我們先看的是光通訊好先發獎狀兩檔光通訊低價的瑞瑄最近表現很強高價的大立光也是表現很強
高低價真的都蠻青睞光通訊這個族群的
沒錯我們一把幫大家掌握了
因為上禮拜來講的時候
我們就有提到過這一波的反彈
我們都會先看到季節
很順利的今天一根漲停板
漲停板40.55
一個禮拜漲30%不錯啦不錯啦
那大立光來說的話
我們前面也是他在回檔修正的時候
已經跌無可跌 就是減便宜的概念
那到了今天 其實沿著五日均線往上走
我認為大力光在這邊都還沒有這個
去做停利的條件
中長線應該都還是有高點可以做期待
好 所以我們的小資族
也許可以選低價的法人投信
非常青睞大力光
沒錯 是的 用零股操作也是一種方式
那再來的話以IC設計
我們今天帶來的當然一方面就是
所謂的IPC制裁
這邊的估值會稍微高一點
可是呢 不要忘記他們的營收
营收都是創歷史新高
最新公布出來的
真的有基本面在支撐
另外這座伺服器的
這個晶片管理IC的信華
股王嘛
加油不要被窗戶超車了
加油頂住
那另外近期啊
像瑞育這些
我認為網通控制IC
股價相對的就比較疲軟一點點
那最主要是因為他們的營收
你第一個他沒有辦法創新高
數字也沒有到特別漂亮
反而是2450聯發科
等一下我們會來聊
我認為雖然他目前的營收年增率
數字不漂亮
但是因為他的獲利成長性
在明年算是一個蠻高度確定的
現在有被低估
我們在這邊去看的話呢
我個人會特別去關注到底
投信跟外資他們分別去買誰
所以像創意來講的話
投信跟外資都正在買方
這種股票我們就可以特別去做關注跟鎖定
我們先來看聯發科好了
送軟他
真的要送軟也蠻多朋友
就說怎麼會連跌個不停
因為前面有利空
但這個利空其實也不是大利空
就是什麼單子被AMD搶走
還在擔心這個事情
其實不需要擔心
因為聯發科跟 Google 他們這一個 TPU 的專案是 Code Design
Code Design 的這種深度綁定
不太可能隨便一個人進來就把它換掉
好 我直接告訴大家
在今年跟明年預估的 EPS 分別是 67.9 跟 150
所以明年的 EPS 是翻倍成長
你股價怎麼會被莫名其妙壓在月線下面
我覺得這個是不合理的啦
我覺得是不合理的
Google 的 TPU 這件事情有造成影響
它目前營收還沒有辦法大幅有提升
這兩件事情就讓它現在有一點點被壓制
有一點被壓抑
但反而是這種時候是我會覺得逢低減便宜的
原因是因為今年Google TPU的ASIC專案
是第四季開始量產
所以營收會開始灌出來
〔此段辨識失敗，約 40:00 起〕